[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 dans
l'actualité de ce mardi 26 septembre
retour sur la visite de Gabriel Attal au
rectorat de Versailles hier le ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse a rencontré les équipes de
l'Académie visaient actuellement par de
nombreuses critiques 55 courriers jugés
inappropriés ont été envoyés dans les
derniers mois des familles dont les
enfants étaient victimes de harcèlement
un audit a été lancé au sein du rectorat
il a été inauguré le 27 septembre 1993
le théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines fait en
2023 ses 30 ans d'existence pour
l'occasion la scène nationale proposait
des animations pendant deux jours
spectacleont toujours et concert nous
étions sur place lui a attendu ses 12
ans pour changer d'identité le Cabaret
du bout des prés à Cernay-la-Ville opte
pour un nouveau nom la chouette objectif
promouvoir la capacité du lieu à
accueillir de multiples événements les
responsables souhaitent également
contrer certains stéréotypes sur le
cabaret et puis l'invité du 7-8 en
deuxième partie d'édition on y parle de
tout en forêt au programme ce mercredi
l'événement a pour but de valoriser ce
patrimoine naturel grâce à des échanges
entre des spécialistes et le public 8
forêts sont concernées dans les Yvelines
l'académie de Versailles dans la
tourmente depuis plus d'une semaine
l'institution est visée par plusieurs
polémiques suite à des courriers
adressés aux parents d'enfants victimes
de harcèlement pour rappel une lettre de
réprobation avait été adressée à la
famille du collégien Nicolas menacé dans
son établissement le jeune de 15 ans
c'était suicidé le 5 septembre dernier à
Poissy les propos que vous avez tenus et
le comportement que vous avez eu en vert
des personnels de l'Éducation nationale
dont le professionnalisme et l'intégrité
n'avait pas être remise en cause de la
sorte sont inacceptables je les retrouve
de la façon la plus vive un autre
courrier similaire de l'académie de
Versailles avait été envoyé au père
d'une fillette de 11 ans à Andrésy
victime d'attouchement sexuel par un
animateur périscolaire ce lundi 25
septembre le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse Gabriel
Attal était au rectorat pour faire le
point sur cette situation de crise un
audit a été lancé dans l'académie sur
l'année scolaire 2022 2023 120 courriers
dit de réprobation ont été adressés
sur ces 120 courriers de réprobation qui
ont été adressés 55 d'entre eux semblent
poser question évidemment des travaux
vont se poursuivre pour
identifier ce qui a mené à l'envoi de
ses courriers en réponse le ministre des
taillé plusieurs mesures chaque académie
aura désormais davantage de moyens infa
d'engager du personnel dans la lutte
anti-arcellement d'ici la fin de l'année
2023 pour gérer les situations les plus
rapidement possible et avec le plus
d'humanité possible la deuxième chose
c'est aussi un fait nouveau c'est que
désormais les académies les rectorats
seront évalués aussi sur la gestion des
situations de harcèlement au sein de
leur académie ce mercredi Gabriel Attal
est la première ministre Elisabeth borne
annonceront un plan dans la lutte contre
le harcèlement scolaire
[Musique]
transport il y a du nouveau sur les
lignes n etu du Transilien 12 trains
supplémentaires sont désormais proposés
chaque semaine sur l'axe Paris
Montparnasse Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Montigny-le-Bretonneux terminus
Rambouillet c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour les usagers avec des temps de
parcours allant de 19 à 21 minutes c'est
un supplémentaire vont leur permettre de
gagner jusqu'à 18 minutes sur leur
trajet c'était ce mardi 26 septembre
université Versailles 50 ans les mines
organisé son forum de rentrée à
Guyancourt plus de 45 associations
étaient présentes sur place l'occasion
pour les étudiants de s'inscrire dans
des structures sportives culturelles ou
encore humanitaires les animations
étaient également au programme en sport
le vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Yvelines va accueillir début janvier les
championnats de France de cyclisme sur
piste l'occasion pour le public de voir
en action les futurs pistards français
qui seront présents aux Jeux olympiques
de 2024 Mathilde gros Florian grimbaud
ou encore Marie divine quoi mais seront
présents la billetterie devrait ouvrir
prochainement ce sera la troisième fois
après 2014 et 2019 que le vélodrome
national accueille les championnats de
France
[Musique]
30 ans ça se fête en chanson et en danse
inaugurée en 1993 le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines incarnait une
volonté politique forte apporter la
culture à tous et 30 ans plus tard cette
volonté n'a pas changé
ce théâtre
national
dont on en est très fier c'est un
symbole et en plus c'est un peu le
vaisseau amiral comme on dit aussi de la
culture à Saint-Quentin mais même
au-delà dans une ville il est essentiel
d'avoir des lieux de culture comme
celui-ci parce que c'est ça qui permet
d'abord d'aller vers l'autre de créer du
lien avec les habitants et en même temps
cette culture ce que l'on apprend ce que
l'on nous donne à voir ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qui fait grandir les gens
et donc c'est essentiel dans une ville
une ville accomplie d'avoir une scène
nationale et je pense qu'on a vraiment
beaucoup de chance de l'avoir ici sur
Saint-Quentin à Montigny pour fêter ses
30 ans le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est la
médiathèque du canal ou organiser un
week-end festif
c'était aussi l'occasion pour l'équipe
de la scène nationale de partager sa
prochaine saison culturelle qui sera
composée de 60 spectacles on essaie de
se demander qu'est-ce que les publics
les spectateurs dans leur grande
diversité
pour aimer qu'ils ne savent pas encore
qu'ils aiment mais ça veut dire aussi
que on va la recherche de plein de
jeunes artistes et que ce lieu est pas
seulement un lieu dans lequel on vient
voir des artistes que l'on connaît mais
aussi des lieux un lieu dans lequel on
vient découvrir des artistes danse
musique cirque il y en a pour tous les
goûts je suis fidèle au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin oui pour sa programmation
diverses
pour toute catégorie confondues c'est
très novateur c'est des scènes qu'on
retrouve pas forcément dans nos
banlieues le théâtre de Saint-Quentin
propose beaucoup de danses
et c'est vrai qu'en fonction des
différentes villes les théâtres sont
plus axés sur un domaine où l'autre donc
ça permet d'avoir un panel de
proposition je suis abonnée et je viens
très très souvent en plein de concerts
différents ce qui est l'avantage c'est
qu'il y a une programmation très
très diverses donc on peut tester plein
de choses et le théâtre de 50 ans en
Yvelines se tourne vers l'avenir en
janvier 2024 il se lance dans des
travaux de rénovation avec notamment la
construction d'un café et d'un
restaurant la programmation se fera
alors à l'extérieur des murs dans une
quinzaine de lieux différents
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Thomas perron Arnaud directeur
du prisme en cours alors aujourd'hui je
vais vous donner trois raisons de
devenir voir la promesse brêle à au
prisme
la première c'est l'histoire
complètement dingue de du chanteur qui
travaille au stup qui a commencé à
chanter Brel sur pendant une plante la
deuxième c'est les musiciens qui
l'accompagnent co accompagner Barbara
Aznavour à l'idée voilà donc c'est quand
même du très très haut niveau musical et
la dernière raison c'est juste pour le
spectacle en fait c'est pour ceux qui
ont jamais vu Bruel c'est très très
étonnant en fait très proche qui a pu
être à l'époque enfin c'est très
étonnant comme comme spectacle
[Musique]
j'ai voulu voir ta sœur et on a vu quand
même toujours quand on a que l'amour
fou rire cela
ton uni combat
voilà c'était mes trois raisons de venir
voir la promesse Brel au prisme le
samedi 14 octobre à 20h30
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
appelez-le désormais la chouette après
12 ans d'existence le Cabaret du bout
des prés installé à Cernay-la-Ville
change d'identité un nouveau nom pour
casser les idées reçues sur le cabaret
un mot trop souvent victime de préjugés
on s'en aperçut depuis ces dernières
années avec pourquoi pas même des
parents d'élèves qu'on côtoie
régulièrement qui met du temps à venir
et puis finalement viennent et disent ah
mais on regrette de pas être venu plus
tôt parce qu'ils avaient des préjugés
peur de voir trop de nudités ou des
choses comme ça alors que cabaret c'est
du spectacle avant tout la chouette veut
montrer aussi qu'elle ne manque pas de
ressources au menu de sa programmation
des comédies musicales
[Musique]
des spectacles hommages au plus grands
tubes contre cela pas de chanter
[Musique]
ou encore du théâtre les possibilités
sont nombreuses déjà la possibilité
d'accueillir des entreprises pourquoi
pas pour faire du Team Building et puis
les coachers et ouvrir pour des
spectacles pour enfants
faire des manifestations
culinaires pourquoi pas aussi des
manifestations
artistiques faire des expositions ou des
choses comme ça enfin voilà tout est
vraiment Open et parmi les nouveautés
cette saison la chouette jouera les 10
et 11 novembre son tout nouveau
spectacle génération 80 un voyage dans
le temps pour revivre les succès
musicaux les émissions cultes et les
produits mémorables de cette période
iconique
[Musique]
je suis avec Dimitri Seb Alex et Enzo
ils font partie du groupe premier métro
il participe au Versailles live à un
tremplin des voies organisé à Versailles
et dédié aux jeunes talents du
territoire on a trop trop hâte là
franchement on va jouer là tout à
l'heure sur la grande scène et avec les
gars on est trop chaud on a envie de se
lâcher tout péter quels sont les styles
musicaux justement que vous allez
aborder ce soir principalement du rock
après on fait aussi un peu de la pop des
synthé un peu années 80 et le but c'est
que tout le monde passe un bon moment
qu'on danse ensemble
chaque membre du groupe se met des
paillettes sous les yeux avant les
concerts pourquoi est-ce que vous vous
faites ça ben alors en fait les
paillettes c'est des paillettes c'est
des larmes de paillettes en fait qu'on
se trace sous les yeux et c'est parce
qu'en fait on a fait tellement la teuf
jusqu'à 5 6 du match en fait que les
paillettes elles ont coulées pendant
toute la nuit et c'est le maquillage
voilà de fin de teuf qu'on se met sous
les yeux ça nous fait un petit temps
avec les gars pour être tu vois
tranquille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Versailles c'est maintenant
[Musique]
c'est que je suis encore parti
est-ce que vous connaissez ce groupe
avant de participer au Versailles live
excellent on l'adore
alors ce concert un truc de ouf c'était
trop trop bien les émotions là
tranquille
justement les gens les gens ils sont
trop bien là le public ils sont ils sont
trop à fond et c'est émouvant tu vas
toucher ouais vraiment
musical le groupe premier métro gagne un
chèque de 1500 euros ils seront
également à la prochaine édition de la
Fête de la Musique à Versailles on n'a
pas fini de parler d'eux puisqu'ils vont
sortir un EP en début 2024
un ciel voilé dans la matinée de
mercredi dans les Yvelines il fera 14
degrés dans les secteurs de Versailles
Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet 15 degrés
à Houdan des éclaircies dans
l'après-midi pour les températures il
fera 24 degrés sur l'ensemble du
département et demain mercredi 27
septembre nous fêterons les Vincents
tout de suite l'invité du 7 8 avec
Régine ralech
[Musique]
la forêt française joue un rôle
essentiel dans la conservation de la
biodiversité et face aux enjeux
économiques environnementaux et
sociétaux que rencontrent les forêts de
France l'Office National des Forêts
organisent le 27 septembre prochain un
temps d'échange entre des spécialistes
et le public alors ça se passera dans 80
forêts domanielle et régionales en
France dans les Yvelines 9 sites sont
concernés et pour en parler avec nous
Michel Béal bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le directeur de l'agence
territoriale ONF Île-de-France ouest
alors tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer l'importance de ce
type de journée effectivement très
important pour nous avec 12 millions
d'habitants les Franciliens
s'intéressent à la forêt viennent en
forêt très souvent et par contre il la
connaissent mal il l'ignore et donc
souvent on a beaucoup de questions et on
s'est dit pourquoi pas une journée
dédiée à l'accueil du public et à la
sensibilisation des publics et donc on
est pour les accueillir ce jour-là alors
justement cet après-midi comment est-ce
qu'elle se déroule et ce qu'il y a des
échanges des balades comment ça se passe
exactement on a fixé dans les grandes
forêts domaniale des Yvelines mais
également dans toute leur reste de la
région parisienne des lieux de rencontre
où il y aura sur ces lieux de rencontre
deux ou trois ou quatre personnes de
l'ONF les forestiers de terrain qui
connaissent bien la forêt mais également
ce jour-là il y aura les autres
personnes de l'ONF qui seront également
sur le terrain et ça sera sur ces lieux
de rencontre à 14h le mercredi 27
septembre que pourront venir tous les
habitants tous les riverains ceux qui
veulent et on parle dans cette journée
on parle de forêt domaniale mais aussi
de forêts régionales c'est quoi la
différence exactement tout à fait depuis
l'année dernière la région Île-de-France
qui est propriétaire de forêt est venu
se retrouver dans cette opération
donc ça ça va se passer à la fois dans
les forêts domaniales c'est celle qui
appartiennent à l'État c'est l'État qui
est propriétaire comme la forêt de
Rambouillet comme la forêt de
Fontainebleau la forêt de Saint-Germain
mais il y aura également des points de
rencontre avec les personnels de
Île-de-France nature qui gère les forêts
régionales comme la forêt de Ferrières
en Seine-et-Marne par exemple est-ce que
vous savez à peu près les types de
questions qui reviennent le plus souvent
puisque c'est la troisième édition que
vous organisez et quels sont les points
de difficultés ou de questionnements que
rencontrent les citoyens souvent le
citoyen qui vient en forêt il pense la
forêt comme un décor mais il voit pas
toujours
ce milieu naturel complexe mais aussi
gérer ces forêts sont entretenus sont
gérés si elles ont cette qualité
paysagère c'est parce qu'elles sont
gérées depuis cinq siècles six siècles
donc souvent les questions c'est ce que
j'appellerai des fois les du temps pour
le public pourquoi les coupes de bois à
quoi ça sert où est-ce que va le bois
pourquoi il y a de la chasse donc c'est
des questions de ce type là qui
reviennent le plus souvent et bien sûr
comme c'est notre métier on répond à
toutes alors est-ce qu'il y a aussi des
questions qui sont en rapport avec les
enjeux climatiques qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui ou la coupe des arbres par
exemple tout à fait tout à fait c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui notamment dans les
Yvelines les certaines forêts souffrent
du changement climatique une essence en
particulier on souffre c'est le
châtaignier on a des châtaigniers autour
de nous certains châtaigniers sont
atteints d'une maladie maladie qui s'est
développée à cause du changement
climatique donc il y a grand nombre
notamment en forêt de Marly dans les
Yvelines des châtaigniers qui meurent
qui sont nécessairement coupés parce
qu'une fois qu'ils sont morts on n'a pas
d'autres
issus bien sûr après il y a des
replantations donc c'est ces questions
là qu'on pourra aborder le changement
climatique comment il se dans nos forêts
ici en Île-de-France les forestiers
seront là ce jour-là pour répondre à
toutes les questions et aux enfants qui
pourront venir puisqu'on est un mercredi
et justement face à ces questions
quelles sont les enjeux que rencontrent
les forêts des Yvelines actuellement les
grands enjeux les grands enjeux
finalement on retrouve bien le triptyque
qu'on peut avoir dans l'ensemble des
forêts je dirais la particularité des de
l'Île-de-France et des Yvelines c'est
que les trois enjeux principaux sont
bien équilibrés en jeu de fréquentation
avec 10 millions d'habitants les forêts
les forêts d'Île-de-France sont sans
doute les plus fréquentées de France
avec évidemment pour répondre à la
demande sociale d'accueillir le public
en forêt
l'enjeu l'enjeu de biodiversité ces
forêts sont souvent riches d'une grande
réservoir de biodiversité avec des
espèces parfois rares parfois protégées
liés à la présence de
une vieille forêt de vieux arbres ou de
milieux humides le la mission de l'ONF
ici en Île-de-France c'est de préserver
cette biodiversité et bien sûr à
quelques kilomètres de Paris la France
n'a jamais eu autant besoin de bois donc
entretenir la forêt ça passe aussi par
des coupes de bois et donc il y a
l'enjeu économique il est aussi
important dans notre région alors c'est
la troisième fois que l'événement
revient est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui rassemble vous attendez combien de
personnes à peu près l'année dernière à
l'échelle de l'Île-de-France était plus
de 1000 personnes qu'il y avait on
espère qu'il y en aura beaucoup plus
cette année en tout cas grâce à au
Relais des communes des collectivités
avec lequel nous travaillons
l'information a été largement passée et
on espère que beaucoup de Franciliens
viendront ce jour-là encore plus
nombreux que l'année dernière bien merci
si vous aussi vous souhaitez participer
à cet événement sachez qu'il est gratuit
ce sera le 27 septembre à 14h voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
Michel belle pour cette interview et en
attendant le 27 je vous souhaite de
passer une excellente soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]